yeah i always wondered about i'm sure
i'm not like i'm sure many people have
asked that question before but it's like
have you
if you come in a chick in the holodeck
where does the come go i'll ask ryker he
if anybody knows like a hologram if you
come in a holographic chick yeah like
you cause obviously you're going to raw
dog it right she's a hologram
yeah i know so you're going to raw it's
a hologram just to be safe
fair enough you want to be safe but you
know you're going to raw dog these
holographic
right so let's say you just get a good
nut in there
um and then somebody's like all right uh
jordy power down the holodeck
look where does the comm go i mean i'm
assuming somebody like one of those
lower
people or they have an intern like have
to go in there and mop it and ensign
an ensign's in there like [ __ ]
wesley's in their mop and come
yeah you have two jobs here on the ship
as a red shirt you can either go with
the away team
or you can clean up [ __ ] on the holodeck
you think about it right if you're a red
shirt and star trek
you take the come sweeping job right
your choices are you ready you got a red
shirt on two choices
away team or you get to clean up to come
online i'm cleaning up the comments yeah
because i want to live like alive yeah
you're like i mean it's a terrible job
but it's [ __ ] imagine getting
murdered
but the other thing is like i love all
the that that's one of the other things
star trek like
the the the unrealistic things
and it's like all these like oh yeah
they go on the i'm gonna go on the
holodeck and pretend i'm
robin hood or i'm gonna go be play
sherlock holmes
99 of holodeck stuff is [ __ ]
you know which makes you wonder why do
you need a pleasure planet why do you
need ryzer for anyway
it seems like a waste you could just
[ __ ] a chick yeah and not only that
like they probably do some dark [ __ ]
because like which which also then you
start thinking about
eventually holograms become like
sentient like with a doctor you can
voyager for example it's like hey this
these holograms like have feelings and
[ __ ] so they've just been
murdering people like there's a lot of
complexities well i think because the
holodeck would be considered for
instance like prostitution right like
look if you go to a hooker but they have
no choice they're programmed to do more
like sex slaves really
but that's it but what i'm saying is you
go to the holodeck right and it's the
same like
like when you go to a prostitute you're
just trying to get a nut in
because it's been a while or whatever so
you pay a hooker but there's no
you're not patting yourself on the back
there's no like yeah i got laid
like nobody says that nobody says you
get a hooker
so maybe the holodeck is that mental
equivalent of like all right well let's
i'm just just [ __ ] a hologram but if
you go to ryzen 7 or whatever riser or
whatever the [ __ ] planet is right
you get your dick sucked by a real chick
and and even though
i don't think you earned it though but
again they're pretty much rise as a
planet of prostitutes but i
but i think it's presented differently
right yeah it is it's it's presented
night it's it's like
it's like when you get upper end yeah
it's like when you go to a really nice
hotel like a really nice one like a
country club type hotel
and they don't take any cash from you
everything you just sign for and it's
very like oh
you know and they just bring you things
right yeah you know it's it's presented
a different way like you're still paying
for that [ __ ] right
but nobody brings up the bill at a
country club nobody's ever like ah
sir your tab for dinner earlier because
it's like you're a member they're gonna
get the money from you it's all worked
out so you just walk
you can walk around just take an hors
d'oeuvre and a champagne and take things
from people and they go i just charge
the room so
i'm thinking that's probably the
pleasure plan it's more like you can
feel like you're just in in the thick of
it
unless of course your picard which all
these just want to [ __ ] picard
but you made me think of something cause
you said who cleans up the [ __ ] can't you
just transport the [ __ ] into space
that's true you just transfer you don't
need to clean holodeck to engineering
every time if you follow the enterprise
it's just a trail of [ __ ] who's that
irish guy
oh chief o'brien that poor guy chief
o'brien yeah
chief o'brien's in charge of teleporting
all of the ships come
out in this but then we know but then
what if you see how much space come
yeah because then it's it's sort of like
why people always ask why don't we just
put all our garbage in space because
there's already a lot of space debris
well you can't get through the dome the
dome as well
and the van allen belts
but um but they tell you like there's
already so much
junk in space for mistakes we've made
that like that
they're putting the space station at
risk they put other shuttles at risk you
hit a piece of space debris and you're
done
so we can't keep dumping garbage out
into space maybe the common is the same
thing maybe it's impossible
because imagine like you're flying
through space and your spaceship hits
calm
and it gets all over the sensors and all
the you know
the whatever the is it a windshield do
they have windshields on the bridge
whatever it is and then screen a view
screen yeah and then try getting that
off you got to try to get it off right
away
or it's going to [ __ ] smear and also
prime directive comes into play so like
what if the com lands on a planet and
you make your own creatures you start
evolution because of your [ __ ]
that's true you see you can't risk you
can't it really [ __ ] with the prime
directive so
i think what we're talking about
honestly is the most important thing
going on in this country right now so
they just get rid of i think they keep
to come on the ship in the little
biohazard bags like the hospital
and then when they go to like a space
station so like deep space nine they
probably drop a lot of comfort the
problem with that is george takai was
also always sneaking in there with a
capri sun straw
my yeah yes
because he was a visual and he likes [ __ ]
i sure wish anthony rapp had done that
with macomb
but these new school actors just don't
have any appreciation for the craft
the craft of [ __ ] sucking of course i'm
not talking about acting
i don't do that anymore he still doesn't
he still does the former though
i'm a youtube creator my name is kevin
spacey and if you don't give me my
plaque susan i'm going to
every boy on this platform like and
subscribe
i'll [ __ ] shane dawson in his ass right
on the front page
of youtube if i don't get my plaque well
there's no that's not a threat for
anybody everyone in that situation would
like it
who would not like it no even shane
dawson would be like i'm scared of mr
spacey
get your ass on that bed boy i'm gonna
[ __ ] you like you did to that cat
can you imagine kevin spacey just
becoming a daily youtuber you know a lot
of people were asking me
oh that's right folks make sure you get
your patriot food buckets
and promo code spacey no
promo code underwood you know what i
just used
i was executive producer on that show i
dare them to sue me
oh could you imagine like he keeps doing
those little bits you imagine if they
sued him
because it's like i i get it you know
obviously
legally there there's reasons why you
can't just use that character but like
that's that was spacey's show like like
i understand
whatever and i look they should have
fired him like they didn't fire people
who
seem to misunderstand that kevin spacey
got fired for all the allegations
against him
kevin spacey was already under
investigation for like very actively is
like allegedly like sex groping and like
people on that side that's what i'm
saying like
production assistance and key grips they
were already looking into spaces don't
name them key grips then
that's true they should have given you
asking for it yeah and also
let's let's talk about the title of best
boy
i thought that i thought it had entirely
different connotations to it
but like yeah he got fired because they
already had this like
thick open active case file on him
within the company
and then this happened and they were
like we got to fire spacey but
he should be allowed to portray that
character forever because there is no
house of cards without kevin spacey
that was his baby they should have let
him finish
ah they should have just like warned
everybody like look you don't have to
work here but you're probably going to
get raised by spacey
then wait how many times do i get it but
do i do i get to be on house of cards
but
yeah but that's the point right then you
can make an informed decision
right and then if you decide to still go
in and work with spacey then it's like
all right you sign a waiver and they go
look we told him he's probably gonna get
but he really wanted to work with spacey
like the santa claus but for like spacey
yeah okay i like that that's pretty much
the dynamics of hollywood
the way dynamics of hollywood have
always been where you just go
look like like it's marlon brando i know
he wrote that [ __ ] on last tango in
paris but like
it's marlon brando like you know what i
mean josh uh
joe says uh without spacey that show
collapsed like like uh building seven
that's not true
there was a reason the show collapsed
yeah that show collapsed like some kind
of uh
house of uh i don't know like um
something that wasn't
structured something that maybe doesn't
have the right support system in place
to hold up the structure some kind of
house made of things that are flimsy
uh right um
i love that the fact that the show is
called house of cards
and your analogy was man with space you
got out of that show that
show collapsed like building seven
yeah or i don't know a house of cards
all right
uh i mean we titled it house of cards
how did they not see it coming
slurp pepsi excuse me holla deck
replicator's
energy into matter it's not a
holographic device
don't be a [ __ ] nerd come on man
we're already nerds enough
captain to engineering we need a we're
gonna need four
ensigns to clean up the holiday kevin
spacey has been in here
all day and the holodeck is simply caked
with [ __ ]
it looks like the inside of a cave
formation